man wears many hats he is not only an
analyst for nbc sports boston and
primarily the senior nba writer
for sports illustrated but also uh a
host of
design boxing and there's big news on
that front as well always appreciative
to see you here in studio chris mannix
good to be here rich all right let's get
let's start with the association
first uh and your association with the
uh
covering of the celtics what in the
world happened on this famed plane
flight
that allowed this celtics team to turn
the corner
from seemingly uh a mess
to championship caliber team here if the
celtics like
if they wind up doing something in the
playoffs like this plane is going to be
clearly dissected for weeks and months
said to every little detail of getting
on the plane to what happened who went
the bathroom first like
this this is like durant's hamptons
exactly potentially the one thing i've
heard coming out of boston was that this
this was a very positive conversation
they had now they've had a lot of
you know airing of the grievance type
meetings
last year a lot of festivus stuff
they've had closed door meetings they've
talked i mean
marcus morris say earlier in the season
that it just wasn't fun
you know playing like that anymore this
what i was told had
a much more different tone it was kyrie
irving speaking a handful of other guys
speaking but speaking more
in a positive way about what this team
really is capable of which was
interesting because they were coming off
a brutal home stand they were slapped
around by the houston rockets but
on that plane ride out west they were
very positive and
for whatever reason that manifested
itself in just what's been a terrific
road trip so
positive i mean was it
kyrie and brad stevens well did they all
get together best you can tell on the
plane
no i don't think there was a look i mean
for context and these plane rides all
the players kind of sit in one group
some of them play cards some of them
take naps
um but during this this plane ride it
wasn't the coaching staff that was
talking it was the players
talking amongst themselves and really
just saying uh from what i was told like
we're better than this we are a really
good team and look that's a reality you
know what we saw against golden state
maybe not beating them by
you know 30 points but beating them is
something this team
is capable of doing going to sacramento
winning on back to back beating the
lakers being the clippers
beating top-tier teams this celtic group
is fully capable of doing that i mean
we forget sometimes just how good they
were at the end of last year
and now that we see this team starting
to come together specifically when it
comes to gordon hayward like
individually
that's the story gordon hayward had a
couple of clunkers
in february but that month was a pretty
good month for him
and he's off to a great start in march
he's never going to be at least not this
season
gordon hayward from utah but gordon
hayward 2.0
who shoots a high percentage from three
who operates as basically the backup
point guard
that player can still be really
effective so i think you have to look at
hayward
and what he's doing as a real catalyst
more than any kind of you know plane
trip let me throw something out at you
chris mannix
the mental part of all of this that
kyrie seems to talk about a lot
and other players as well the mental
aspect the glare
hey you're following me into a hallway
and you're trying to read into my
conversation with another
free agent to be and that drives me
crazy and steve kerr comes and says hey
we're all part of a soap opera that's
what you get paid big bucks for
that plane ride or not obviously gordon
hayward is a big difference maker as
well
but we're at the point of the season
where july 1st
is finally for the first time all season
secondary
that we're now in the nitty and the
gritty that anybody that has a question
about their july first intentions could
easily say
not now this is the playoffs we're
making a playoff push these are the
playoffs
and that mentally helps unlock somebody
like kyrie irving what are your thoughts
on that
i think that's true um you know
kyrie there are some guys that love free
agency right like
lebron loved it kevin durant maybe
doesn't love it so much but certainly
it doesn't affect him to talk about that
much this is kyrie irving's first foray
into free agency
and you can tell from jump he doesn't
like it he doesn't like the whole
process
he doesn't like the questions about it
all that being said kyrie does
a magnificent job of feeding the media
without the media even asking questions
like the call with lebron
that he had nobody asked him about it
nobody has to reach out to lebron
we're talking about a plane ride nobody
asked him about it
he just dropped that after the game
against the warriors
and you know the the the stuff that
happened in new york when he when he
kind of lost it and said ask me july 1st
that was weird too because he had to
know going into that uh that press
availability
that this was going to be the question
like for 24 hours he knew
after the knicks did what they did that
this was going to be the question he
just seems to handle
all this this media stuff very strangely
and i think that's a
a big part of of what's kind of been you
know sort of dysfunctional about him
this season and another reason why
july 1st might not be as prominent
is we're seeing the warriors lose to the
suns last night
yeah the narrative that the celtics
helped feed
that demarcus cousins is a defensive
liability
and may not be helpful on that
not only on that side of things once the
playoff hits but give them
two players that can be easily triggered
in a playoff situation
also a lip reader's delight
on twitter last night of steve kerr
saying
something profane about being sick of
draymond's you know what
and it sure looks like that so
do we see right now a warriors team that
is
there for the taking do you think i
think they are certainly more vulnerable
than they've been at any point in the
last few years including last year
when they were down 3-2 for the reasons
you kind of articulated there
first there are clearly it's not
as tight a locker room has been in the
past the kevin durant stuff
has obviously worn on that team uh
draymond green
is a lot to deal with like he is still
the heart and soul of that team
but he is a lot over the course of an 82
game season because of how emotional
he gets out there on the floor and this
is a season where he's only shooting
about 25
from three so he's been far less
effective in his time out there on the
floor so the internal stuff is a factor
but to your point about demarcus cousins
he's playing like 25 30 minutes per game
right now for golden state
he can't play that many minutes in the
playoffs you can use the rest of the
regular season
as a glorified kind of pre-season for
cousins try to work things
out and get him into the kind of shape
you need him in the playoffs but
everything i've seen from watching the
warriors and talking to coaches
that have played the warriors and you
saw the celtic game when he's out there
on the floor
they go at him immediately pick and
rolls uh any kind of switching that gets
him out there on the floor
and who's the biggest threat to golden
state it's houston right the rockets
continue to be the biggest threat to
golden state what do they do well
get you on a switch and play pick and
roll they've got two
elite pick-and-roll type players in
james harden and chris paul
and they're just gonna go at demarcus
cousins all day long so what happens in
that series if you can't play cousins
how does cousins handle it does that
contribute
to any kind of strife in the locker room
i think they're just a lot of warning
signs
about this golden state team what about
the east too i mean uh
tobias harris seems to be fitting in
very well with a sixers team that gets
embiid back he looked
terrific we all know what the bucks have
looked like they're the only 50-win team
currently
in the association the raptors and the
pacers
um might fall off a little bit here the
pistons are coming on strong is it
you think that they have an opportunity
here in the western conference
uh when they meet up in the nba finals
in the east of the
east can the east pull it together and
win oh absolutely um
look boston's four and four against
golden state in the last what three
years four years
uh they play them as well as anybody
because they can switch
on all those golden state players but
the eastern conference you know one
through four
i take i hate taking indiana out because
they've been such an overachiever but
you can't count on them to win the
players
indiana didn't have a single
representative at all-star weekend
olivia would have been that guy sure but
they didn't have anybody in the futures
game or the skills competition
they had nobody representing them so a
team without that type of talent
it's problematic but any one of those
top four teams including philadelphia
can make a run throughout the playoffs
and that's why a team like boston
has not been looking around saying man
we got to get that three seed we can't
fall into that five seed
all they want to do is be playing good
basketball going into the playoffs
because they can win
anywhere and there isn't a boogeyman
atop that conference i mean gold i mean
milwaukee's been leading for a while
but there are a lot of people in the
league that look at the bucks as being a
great regular season team
but some question marks in the playoffs
a lot of guys haven't been there before
at least not deep into the postseason
and they play brook lopez a lot and
brook lopez has been great for their
defense
in the regular season a lot of scouts i
talk to wonder how good he's gonna be in
the playoffs and toronto
i mean toronto should be the favorite
because of their post-season experience
and the fact they've only lost to
cleveland over the last few years
but they're a team certainly with some
young guys that you aren't entirely sure
about so
i think the eastern conference from the
second round on is going to be an
absolute street fight
with so much at stake too like if
toronto loses in the second round
does that affect kawhi leonard does
kawhi does he stay if they go to the
finals do you leave you lose the second
round what about philadelphia
they're about to have the richest
payroll maybe in the history of
basketball if they bring everybody back
do they want to do that if they get beat
in the first round by a celtics team
there's so much on the line uh both for
this season and
seasons beyond the eastern conference
playoffs it's fun it's fun chris maddox
here
on the rich eisen show now let's get to
the lakers i can't believe
that we're sitting here and they're only
one game better than last year at this
point and with 16 games to go
they need to win five of the 16 which is
a
a major undertaking based on their
current situation with the
team the way it's been playing and
obviously who's healthy and who's not
and lebron's not going to play all the
games remaining
and they need five to match last year's
win total they could be
worse with the lebron james signing
than last year so what to do what to do
and in that respect mike del tufo play
what jeff van gundy dropped in the
middle of the celtics lakers broadcast
this week and look i think in the off
season
visiting chris maddox i don't think it's
reality-based because i don't believe
that magic uh or rob polenko would
consider that at this point
but there is merit to that argument it
really is
look the lakers if they don't get
anthony davis this summer
to trade they're in trouble because if
you look at the class
of 2019 the lakers are not atop
any of the wish lit list of the most the
players out there not kawhi not durant
jimmy butler maybe they can overpay for
whatever and then if you fast forward to
2020
to 2020 and assume that if anthony davis
gets traded elsewhere say it's boston
he resigns there that is one of the
weaker unrestricted free agent classes
that we've seen in a while i think
draymond green might be at the top but
there's some good restricted guys
restricted guys never go anywhere
so now you're talking about lebron at 35
36 years old without a top tier player
playing next to him
with the same group of guys in what has
clearly become a locker room with some
major
issues coming back for next season i
think if you get into august
and you see davis go to boston because
by the way if kyrie irving resigns with
the celtics
it's a wrap anthony davis is going to be
traded to the celtics the celtics don't
care if davis says nothing
if kyrie's there they will go all out
and acquire anthony davis
but let's say you get to august and you
don't get anybody
and you're looking at next year saying
all right we got to come back with you
know
the young guys who don't like lebron and
a whole cast of new characters
from the mercenary group like the rondos
the javale mcgees
that you're bringing in i think you have
to start at least exploring the market
i'll tell you which team they should
talk to
okay the denver nuggets last year the
denver nuggets
were frantically trying to get a meeting
with lebron james
they wanted to sign lebron and they
thought they had a great sales pitch
for lebron coming in even on a one-year
deal just coming there
and and and playing with their young
guys the nuggets if they get beat early
in the postseason and they're looking
great right now but if they get beat
early in the postseason
i could see that front office making
calls to the lakers seeing if they're
willing to do a deal
and you heard jeff van gundy say trade
lebron into cap space you really have to
do that with denver
denver would offer you multiple young
pieces they've got a really talented
young roster in denver so you might be
able to get
real assets back in return for the
nuggets and that nuggets front office is
so
you know i say it's in a good way so
bonkers that they would try to get
lebron
and see if they can roll the dice that
lebron jokic and jamal murray can get
them into the finals in the next few
years
that's a team if you it would take huge
you know what to deal lebron james no
question
but if you don't believe that you can
build a championship team
around him in the next two years because
that's really what we're talking about
we've already seen lebron decline over
the last uh you know defensively
certainly
and and various other ways if you don't
think you can build a championship team
in two years
that is absolutely a phone call i would
make so i'll ask the question i'm sure
everyone's asking
he doesn't have a no trade clause in his
contract nba doesn't really do that
there there's certain criteria you have
to meet
to get no trade clause a little bit a
handful of players in
in recent league memory and being the
only guy in the top ten and scoring in
an assist doesn't get you do you think
lebron could ever have imagined
that this would be a topic of
conversation no i know look you know how
many people get
get married without a prenup i mean you
know
i'm using your language mike right i
mean you never think about it you're in
love
with love at first sight and it's not
like you know you see you know in the
nfl
you know guys threatening to retire
braun's not threatening to retire like
he gets straight to the nuggets
he's gonna wind up going there really i
mean his son's about to light it up here
high school-wise he's
i you know what's he gonna do you're
gonna
not go do you think lebron do you think
he regrets this
i don't i can't imagine he thought it
would be this bad at the same time
two things that he never would have
anticipated won the most significant
injury of his career
i mean this was the first time he's
missed 18 plus games right
because of an injury and the davis thing
becoming
so toxic and the davis thing which was
done
in theory to get anthony davis to the
lakers wound up causing
even more damage to the lakers than was
already there because guys were
looking around in the locker room and
this was lebron james coming in
and started the season being like we're
going to build something here we're
going to get make this team a winner i
was at training camp for for
several days listening to these guys
talk about how lebron's going to help us
he's going to teach us we're going to
have a better team
and then you get to late january and
it's like well lebron wants us out of
here because you know his agent
orchestrated
all this with anthony davis so i i don't
i don't think he
i knew expected to be a struggle no way
could he have possibly expected to be
this kind of struggle
all right so then uh a couple more
things for you chris mannix
what's more likely lebron gets traded by
the lakers this
summer or adam silver forces james dolan
to apologize to the fan that he
uh ejected from madison square garden if
not evicted him forever more
first of all you're not getting james
dylan to apologize for anything
like that's just you know the charge
commissioner you're the commissioner you
you've got a video of an owner basically
telling a fan to
hold him for kevin he did he did but by
the way you also in the television only
segment had a very interesting theory
who that kevin is it's not a member of
security
no this yeah this guy said um you know
sell the team
james dolan said uh well you know can't
no no the security guy says
hold him for kevin kevin could have been
kevin durant there we go
hold him for kevin durant who will be
here this time next year so hold him
and let him know that kevin and if
that's the case then
perhaps i can use this video to tell
adam silver to force him to sell the
team with a tampering
adam silver's not forced on the cell
team
he's tampering so force him to sell the
team i think james dolan
and look i say this objectively is just
a bad bad owner
because you can you missed a bad and
that very bad owner
i mean right even now like look at where
we are right now they let christos
borzingers go
and they're backing if kevin durant has
a sign there that
i don't know what that team does well he
lets porzingis go and then triples down
by
barking at a fan yeah i mean he didn't
bark at him he just
calmly you know scorsese movie style
threatened him put it this way and had
to meet with kevin
if the embarrassment of the charles
oakley stuff
uh was it a couple years ago now if that
didn't force the nba to kind of take
some action there
this did he didn't curse at the fan he
didn't you know but he just he
embarrassed himself
in that moment he probably embarrassed
the league in that moment
but adam silver is not forcing james
dolan to sell the team
or not even apologizing never apologize
not even maybe a back channel call
having him say come out you got it you
got to give a statement that he's not
going to embarrass him
by saying you must apologize but call
him up and say
come on man and by the way i'm again
tripling down you trade the purple
unicorn
fans loved that purple unicorn more than
anything else poured all their hearts
and souls and hopes into the purple
unicorn of porzingis
and you triple down by having a video of
you threatening a fan who basically
just heckled you like new yorkers heckle
each other all the time
absolutely and then the fan wasn't you
know using
foul language either you just sell the
team like that's it
like that's the worst that you're going
to hear and that's rude not an opinion
that's rude
and then the whole like the porzingis
stuff you force
you know your front office and the
people in pr to kind of spin it like
it's
porzingis didn't want to be here okay
okay even if he didn't
he had no power over uh over getting out
of there and he wasn't gonna turn down a
max level contract extension that the
knicks offered to him which they were
going to it's just
there's just so much stuff that you just
seen you're like all right well that's
not true and that's not true and that's
not true
all right i went down a little bit of a
dolan wormhole so i do want a
remaining time you're a do zone work uh
there's a big piece of news triple g's
in the house now yeah gennady golovkin
is in los angeles today
he signed a six-fight deal with the zone
and
canelo alvarez we all saw that fight uh
back in september they fought twice now
if canelo alvarez beats danny jacobs
onto zone may 4th
which is an incredibly tough fight uh if
he does that we're going to get a third
fight most likely between golovkin and
canelo in september so there are some
big fights happening so we may get the
we we may get
the trilogy complete here i think we
might get four he finds a six
six fight deal i mean yeah if if it's a
close fight and four yeah we might get
up to that what is it uh who marciano
fought like uh six times
you know back in the day we might get
those those types of sugar ray robinson
uh back
we gotta get sick of four five six
fights between these two guys right
why not if you want to see him go to
dazon
pretty much uh many hats that you have
at si chrismanics on twitter
uh at si chrismanics on instagram as
well love when you are in town
always happy to be here man always happy
to have you here uh
michael irvine still to come here on
this edition of the rich eisen show the
latest on antonio brown and
and we'll check on the uh tell dan don't
don't tell
knows it's okay though it's all right i
just don't it's all right
i'm gonna get a text it's between us do
you really get a text i get a cup of
[ __ ] yeah
same what are you going for rich eyes
and it's usually fritzy like you didn't
text me back
we're we're family i don't understand
but fritz's
fritz i mean he's possessive he's like
the hand of the king very positive not
you do not approach the iron throne
yeah love the game of thrones okay very
good the rich eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience